there are serious questions over the
death of financier Jeffrey Epstein in a
federal holding facility in this state
over the weekend the official
explanation for now is apparent suicide
but the conspiracy theories have been
running rampant the autopsy is complete
but the medical examiner is requesting
more information before making a final
determination
we begin tonight here in new york with
correspondent brian yetta's cadena Brian
good evening Brett as we await the final
results of Jeffrey Epstein autopsy
completed on Sunday today US Attorney
General William Barse slammed the
Metropolitan Correctional Center in
Manhattan New York where Epstein was
found dead after an apparent suicide
Saturday I was appalled and indeed the
whole department was and frankly angry
to learn of the MCCS failure to
adequately secure this prisoner we are
now learning of serious irregularities
at this facility Fox News has learned
that Epstein was not on suicide watch at
the time of his death despite the fact
that he was temporarily put on suicide
watch after he was reportedly found in
his cell with bruising around his neck
two weeks ago Epstein was also not
physically checked on for several hours
leading up to his death even though he
should have been checked on every 30
minutes according to M cc's normal
operations a source familiar with the
situation tells Fox News Epstein did not
have a cellmate at the time of his death
which the source characterized as
unusual the union representing the two
guards on duty in the unit housing
Epstein says one of the guards had
worked 80 hours that week they blame the
Bureau of Prisons and the Trump
administration for all-time low staffing
at MCC over the last three years leading
to overworked guards quote we in Cpl 33
have been sounding the alarm for years
about the hiring freezes the
underfunding and how understaffed our
facilities have been nationwide all
because of the policies of this
administration Jack Johnson a federal
prison consultant says inmates are
rarely left on suicide watch for more
than a week once you get out of that
environment and you're in a special
housing unit or
general population setting you cannot
stop an MA from committing suicide it's
the no policy in the world is going to
prevent that whatsoever as the
Department of Justice and FBI conducted
their investigations conspiracy theories
have flooded the internet including one
unfounded theory retweeted by President
Donald Trump over the weekend that
blamed the Clintons for Epstein's death
Kellyanne Conway defended the tweet on
Fox News Sunday I think the president
just wants everything to be investigated
attorney general Barr also said today
that Epstein's criminal case will
continue against anyone who was
complicit with his alleged sex
trafficking network saying quote any
co-conspirators should not rest easy and
to that end Fox News can confirm the FBI
is currently at Epstein's mansion on his
private u.s. Virgin Island